[Applause]
you're watching swine here's what's
coming up for you in the next 10 minutes
or so here we have a time line and this
is where the work that you upload will
show from Thrones to your phones Alex
gets a look at the app being launched by
Maisie Williams I try out the headset
designed to make weight loss easier and
Lucy's looking for treasure in our games
review now actress Maisie Williams is
best known to millions of Game of
Thrones fans as Arya Stark
a young assassin seeking revenge not
satisfied with a starring role in a
major hit series she's also been busy
developing a brand new form of social
media and she let Alex get one of the
first sneak peeks hello Maisie hi so
obviously well known for Game of Thrones
and all the things you've done on-screen
but you're making a rather interesting
move now into app development
tell me about Daisy so it's still within
the creative arts but so many young
people really struggle to get in to
whichever industry they're looking at
and Daisy will basically provide that
and it will it's a space where young
creators can connect upload share and
have their a platform for their pieces
we're launching in photography music
film art and fashion and yeah we're
already seeing we're already seeing
people uploading their work to social
medias such as Instagram and this is
basically more of a specific career
driven social media what would you say
some of the kind of the biggest problems
that social media poses for young people
particularly creative people because
obviously you share a lot when you share
your work don't you it's almost an
expression of yourself exactly I think
it's the fine line that people will
really struggle to tread which is
whether or not it's safe to upload your
work and whether that's like too much
and people just want to know about what
you have for dinner or whether you know
you're uploading too much about your
life and your personal life and who
you're dating and who you are whatever
so it's nice to have social media that
is solely for people who are interested
in the creative
would like to achieve a career in the
creative arts and it's a place where
they can upload their work connect with
other people that are doing the same
sort of thing and share their projects
to people that are a real sort of
targeted audience to more people like
them who have also kind of felt at
school like they were the weird kid that
wanted to make movies and everyone was
like just get a normal job so it's nice
that there's a place that's solely for
those people one of the big problems
people have online is cyber bullying and
and you've been very honest to be open
about your experience of people online
how are you hoping that Daisy might be
able to you know tackle some of those
pressures so in the playground and also
on social media we have like a real
popularity contest and with Daisy the
way in which your profile will grow is
very different it's not about a fall
account it's about a chain that you make
and to make a chain you work with other
people on the app when you create
projects together and then you have a
mutual link and the more chains that you
make the bigger your profile becomes so
it takes it away from like lots of
people following one person and and
makes it more about the connections that
you're making which is ultimately what
these industries are about you yourself
you're a young woman you know the center
of the entertainment industry and the
tech industry I mean those are two
male-dominated industries what other
kind of challenges you're coming up
again I've I've been very lucky and I've
had a very positive experience in the
film industry and I know that it's not
like that for everyone male or female
and I've already achieved more in my 20
years than I ever thought that I'd Eve
in my life and I kind of just thought
why stop there as a young woman I hope
to inspire other young women that if you
will surprise yourself I've surprised
myself and I hope I continue to with the
rest of my life and I think yeah I think
maybe there's just a knocking confidence
from people from girls from a young age
and I guess I'm here to prove there
doesn't have to be what would you say to
those girls that you can do far more
than you would ever have expected if you
just push yourself and just keep going
if someone tells you no you just
continue on I was just a find it bizarre
how much that I've done I
have to stop because it's such a
fast-paced industry and you don't really
get a chance to sit and like dwell on
anything for too long and every now and
then I have to take a step back and
think like I can't believe that I've
managed to achieve so much and I think
you can really surprise yourself if you
give yourself the credit and young women
really should because we're incredible
absolutely Maisie Williams lovely to
meet you let me talk to you and good
luck with all your filming and of course
with Daisy thank you so much we're
talking next-generation weight-loss
technology now a British neuroscientist
has developed a headset he claims can
help you lose around half a stone that's
more than 3 kilos in 3 months sounds too
good to be true have a look we'll let
you decide
so here's Moody's and we're going to put
this on your head
now it might sound a bit of a funny name
but mo Deus could soon be a device your
doctor prescribes you to help you shift
of body fat Jason who developed the
headset tested it on himself using it
every day for a year and says his body
fat dropped by 44% since then has been
used by around 4,000 people is it doing
anything yet so we haven't turned it on
just yet all that in until the device
turns on I can't feel anything yet yeah
so we're gonna turn it up the headset is
now stimulating my vestibular nerve stay
with me that connects to my hypothalamus
a part of the brain that controls fat
storage metabolism and appetite oh it
smells quickly I starting to feel a
little bit dizzy actually okay yeah if
it's too much we would turn it down so
you're now at level 5 where is it toll
to keep it on for an hour a day to feel
the effects typically what we see the
two most common findings are that people
feel that their appetite goes down quite
quickly but they also feel that their
desire for really high-density sugary
high-calorie foods also decreases and
that's because according to Jason
unlike some weight loss methods that
create a calorie deficit with a risk of
sending your body into famine mode this
one targets your inner thermostat switch
your body's metabolism control center so
your brain doesn't think it needs to eat
so much there's levels oh six feels like
I'm on a boat yeah
we just swing yeah I had to sigh that's
exactly the feeling we want and is this
gonna suppress my hunger today because I
was quite looking forward to lunch
typically it takes about three or four
days before people start to see a
reduction heightens how do you know the
results with Modi's
aren't just a placebo effect yeah I
think that's a question we get asked a
lot and I certainly some people are
gonna buy the device and feel motivated
and grow and be spurred into doing
something that's actually something we
really like but I think it's critical to
say that the laboratory tests that we do
all of the previous work done on
vestibular stimulation she was quite
clear scientific data that this actually
influences their performance I notice
there are a couple of reviews on your
website where people say it didn't work
at all why would that be I think we've
been pretty open and honest with people
and we would say that this is not going
to work for absolutely everyone and we
were certainly excited to see when you
move this from the lab out into the
wider population with people who've
struggled for weight loss for a long
time they might have medication or they
may have like diabetes or thyroid issues
but even they're not really difficult to
treat group we are seeing about 80% of
people have a significant reduction with
the headsets are quite an investment at
369 pounds each but may have an added
positive side effect
Jason tells me that a significant number
of users have reported improved sleep he
had to head off but in the name of
journalism I made myself stay on to
investigate that further videogames time
now he is Lucy with her pick of the
latest releases such a beautiful Kingdom
Leena Kimmy - is the sequel to ninokuni
which came out a few years ago that game
was the collaboration between Japanese
game developers level 5 and Studio
Ghibli frequently referred to as the
Japanese Disney it's basically the story
of the cat people are the ruling class
essentially and the mouse people who are
fed up of being subjugated their whole
lives stage coup and overthrow the young
king Evan and playing as Evan and his
friends you have to learn how to grow up
and how to be able to rule your kingdom
and take it back the combat is very
different if you played the first game
you'll know that the combat was full of
a lot of menus to kind of sift through
and it was turn based in ninokuni - it's
a little action focus it's a lot easier
to play in my opinion if you're looking
for something a little bit different
than the usual video game fare then look
no further than ninokuni to see if these
is the latest game from famed British
game developers rare so if you've ever
wanted to become a pirate and take to
the high seas then now is your chance
because you see if these you and your
friends can band together to form a
pirate crew and you can basically just
head out on your ship onto the high seas
you can search for buried treasure
you can face off against other pirate
crews what I really like about sea of
thieves is that there are different
roles that you have to take on so one of
you can be a navigator from the crow's
nest one of you can be steering the ship
one Manning the cannon it's one of the
most fun multiplayer experiences I think
I've had in a long time because you just
spend the whole time chatting with your
mates and at the same time you're
uncovering cool loot so if you want to
try it see if thieves it's on Xbox one
and PC a way out is a brand new co-op
game where you have to work with your
friend to break out of prison and sort
of stay on the run it is fully co-op so
you can either play together in the same
room you can play split-screen or you
can play online
the interesting thing they're doing with
a way out is that only one of you needs
to own the game in order to feed play it
together with a friend you and your mate
control two different characters Leo and
Vincent and the characters don't really
know each other and you have to work
together in order to escape not only
from the prison but to stay on the
and to stay with free it's very dynamic
in the way that it looks like the camera
angles and the screen sort of shift
around as you progress through the game
there aren't really that many custom
built co-op experiences anymore so it's
just kind of nice to be able to play
games with other people again so if you
fancy a really interesting co-op
experience check out a way out well
that's it for this week's show don't
forget to join us again for more swype
next week and in the meantime follow us
on Twitter
sky news white bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]